a virginia jury's decision to side with
johnny depp in his defamation lawsuit is
drawing both condemnation and praise the
verdict came after six weeks of very
dramatic testimony from both sides she
claimed that he abused her while he said
she was the abuser in his reaction depp
wrote the goal of bringing the case was
to reveal the truth and that truth never
perishes
elaine charlton bredehoff is the
attorney for amber heard and is with us
now and we should mention we did also
reach out to johnny depp's team but they
declined to be interviewed this morning
elaine thank you we're so very glad
you're here thank you uh we heard
amber's reaction uh to the verdict
yesterday this this seems to be a huge
victory for johnny depp this morning
a major setback for women for women
inside the courtroom and outside the
courtroom because because
basically what this said you know amber
had an enormous amount of evidence
although a lot of it was suppressed in
this case as opposed to the uk but look
at all the women who have no evidence
all these women who suffer from domestic
violence domestic abuse
they don't have evidence and basically
what this jury said is unless you pull
out your cell phone and you tape record
your spouse beating you
you're out of luck i think it was bigger
than that because you had the evidence
as you say but they did not believe her
why do you think they did not believe
her
i think that a lot of that was that it
was johnny depp i think the celebrity
status but she's a celebrity too
but wait but she's a yeah but she but
she's a celebrity too right
but you have to remember we it's a tale
of two trials all the evidence came in
in the uk mr depp brought that one the
burden of proof was on the sun in in the
uk because they had called him a wife
beater and talked about the domestic
violence he had his opportunity to tell
the truth then
and a three-week trial he lost the judge
found 12 acts of domestic violence
including sexual violence and that came
out november 2 2020. we weren't allowed
to tell the jury that well it's a
different system and the judge it wasn't
a jury was a judge judge said it was
substantially true uh and that's that is
significant and i think surprised a lot
of legal analysts but you know in this
case the jury
not only didn't believe amber heard but
in ruling that she acted with actual
malice that means she had the intent to
cause harm right that's a pretty high
standard to prove it and it's pretty
amazing since the op-ed never even
mentioned mr depp you have to remember
that what they learned from the uk case
is to demonize amber which is what they
did and to try to suppress as much of
the evidence that came in in the uk and
did not come in in the united states but
the other problem is we had cameras in
the courtroom so here we had not only
did we have a group of depp fans that
were there every day a hundred were
allowed in they lined up at one o'clock
in the morning for their wristbands to
be in that courtroom but we had
everything on camera and we had
tremendous social media that was very
very very much against amber very was
pointed out that that was the first time
that a victim of sexual abuse had to
testify on live television and i fought
hard and lost that battle so it should
not have happened so i'm i am a former
nfl player and after a hard loss it's
easy to wake up and
point to the other side often times i
realize the better thing to do was to
look in the mirror what mistakes did i
make as a player what mistakes did our
coaching staff make and then how can we
improve from there
do you feel like you guys made any
mistakes along the way do you feel like
amber made a mistake while she was on
the stand because you're saying it's the
celebrity it's johnny it's the it's the
people who support him what about you
and your team
well and that's an excellent question
and to say and you know amber even said
on the stand i am not perfect i am a
human being these people were giving her
death threats they threatened to
microwave her baby this is the kind of
social media she was getting so are any
of us perfect no is there something else
we feel we should have done yes i i
absolutely i always i redo my closings a
hundred times
afterwards whether i win or lose um
that's that's part of being a good
lawyer a good trial lawyer is there's
always something but i think that there
were a lot of influences here that were
beyond our control and i think the
social media it was like a roman
coliseum is is the best way to describe
the atmosphere here and i have to
believe that the jury even though
they're told not to go and look at
anything we have you know they have
weekends they have families they have
they were not sequestered
how could they not have been influenced
but elaine for most people watching this
child a lot of people's you know got
huge views it just seemed to be a it
seemed to be so messy and salacious and
so tawdry on both sides on both sides
and i think for the a lot of people from
the outside looking in thought both of
them were not telling the truth and that
they had both that they mutually abused
each other do you not believe that that
was the case no and that's one of the
many misnomers the way that depp's team
approached this was based on ignorance
of domestic violence it they it
completely ignored the cycle of violence
and just said oh she wouldn't have done
this if he had been hitting her that was
their approach you thought that they
weren't fighting fair
correct i i don't think they were
fighting fair how do you think about is
in fact a survivor of domestic violence
yes i absolutely believe that and
there's a tremendous amount of evidence
much of which did not come into this
trial did come into the uk trial we even
had more evidence we had medical records
we had mental health records that went
back to 2012 that were contemporaneous
we had text messages from mr depp's
assistant saying when i told him that he
had kicked you he cried so have you seen
today elaine how is she today what is
her next move she's right well her next
move is appeal there were no heartbroken
she is heartbroken and one of the first
things that she said when she came back
from the verdict when we went into the
conference room was i am so sorry to all
these women
that she said that yes she felt like she
had let down all of these women because
she had more evidence than most people
do and yet they still didn't believe her
elaine charleston bretta hoff thank you
so much for joining us we appreciate you
yeah we'll be right back